and and the idea like jordan peterson
was saying so i couldn't agree because
he goes when you say things like when
you say things like yeah oh you're okay
the way you are no you're not yeah why
are you saying that none of us are okay
the way you you that your existence
doesn't make you special 100 you got to
[ __ ] get better at [ __ ] mm-hmm so
that's
someone said are you all right am i all
right okay you seem a little distracted
oh now dealing with some [ __ ] on the
on the channel okay um
someone said you changed oh i hear it i
hear like back home now you're saying
billy quirky but like billy corgan was
talking about but like yeah i hear but i
was mainly talking about from smashing
pumpkins yeah
and they were like you've changed when
he got successful well yeah you know
it's not it's i don't need a cup of
noodle anymore
hanging out with guys that aren't doing
[ __ ] you just change it's what happens
and you know there's difference between
changing and then going hollywood where
you you only talk to other successful
people that's weird but sometimes those
are the only people that you're around
by the nature of the work you're doing
and you're so busy yeah i don't think
people realize when the people that i
know that i've gotten super successful
are like for example i think rogan told
you he said he gets 60 texts every 10
like hour yeah that's so crazy trying to
get back to everybody is basically
impossible and when you get super
successful you're working 16 hours a day
yeah you're probably out of town you're
probably doing a thousand things so also
you're not gonna put your energy into
that stuff like you only have so many
hours during the day and then he has a
family or stuff like that or you know
you ask me why don't you ever hang out
go to dinner we got kids yeah it's like
i i have very little time to see my kids
yeah i don't between everything
traveling and stuff so the time i have
my kids i can't go to dinner i'm hanging
out with you hanging out with your kids
but but also i think what happens is a
lot of friendships are are predicated on
where we're going where we're headed
when you're young yeah then you get that
mystery and it's like well dude i i did
what i said i was going to do yeah you
guys are doing this
they just stayed the same but somebody
else said when you get there it's really
hard to maintain it's a lot of work it's
not like ah now i can relax your focus
is just different yeah this guy gary vee
was a great you know that gary
vandertuck
i don't know much about him but i
thought he said something really
interesting this guy raises his hand and
goes uh can you talk to me about passive
income like i always wanted he goes what
do you mean he said passive income like
i just want to make enough money so i
can just hang out on a beach and be
making money and he does and he goes
garyvee
he says is that a serious question
and the guy goes yeah he was from sweden
or something yeah and he goes well that
doesn't [ __ ] exist
unless you own crazy amounts of
buildings i guess if you're collecting
rent that is a that is awesome even that
sucks anyway i mean you can though like
if you if you have enough properties
like you're my young my dad has all
these properties and it was a learning
lesson for me because we're on the beach
and he goes you know what the difference
is granted i'm 14. yeah and he goes you
know what the difference between me and
you is like what he goes i'm making
money right now
i'm 14. so
just trying to
yeah i'm trying to get my driver license
yeah i'm excited about that money i was
like oh no doubt yeah trying to get
through eighth grade yeah man you're
you're definitely doing better than me
my dad was 14. my dad was kind of harsh
that way like one time i said i got a c
and he goes a c i said yeah he said
that's okay for you and i i was like it
is it's not a d it's a c yeah that's
pretty good yeah it's pretty good he
goes cool and there was a dude
he was wearing kind of like he looked
like he was out of a movie just a bunch
it was in new york city in the dog this
summer and he's kind of sweating he's
pushing this cart like it was he was
trying to sell i don't know what it was
it's a shitty thing to do to a guy but
he's kind of pushing a cart in his life
so you could just tell this he looked
like he's walking through rain yeah
my dad goes
see that right there
that's a c he gets these
and i get a so what do you want to be
well i do what my dad did to scare me
like i never you know i never drank or
did drugs in college or anything because
my dad when i remember i started to dip
a little my toe in a little in high
school my dad was like
who who who do you want to be like i was
like oh like junior sea or whatever he
goes you know he doesn't drink or doing
that stuff i was like crazy
but you're just as talented so i'm sure
you'll be fine i was like oh so i never
did it so with tiger same thing like
he's into this video game on his
nintendo switch he's super into it and
the last few days when i was home he'll
wake up and you know at 6am he'll go
down there and get on the ipad yeah or
he'll get on his nintendo switch and all
because he's really into football right
now like all we do is play football on
home outside and i go you like that
you're so you're waking up rushing down
playing video games yeah you go tom
brady don't play video games because he
loves tom brady yeah
really i go no never you know what he
does he wakes up and you know he'll read
he'll watch something that informs stuff
like that he's really oh yeah hasn't
touched it since
that hasn't touched and it's it's a
really good tom brady don't play video
games yeah like he might yeah but what's
really interesting is that most of us
when we want to change somebody's mind
it's called you you tell and sell so you
tell them your opinion and then you try
to sell it yeah but people that are if
you think about how you change your mind
a lot of times it's those subtle things
where it's either by example or they
just ask you a question they just ask
you a question they just go what do you
want because i mean i know the guy you
admire doesn't do that yeah that's all
that's my dad didn't mean he's like you
know i mean you know but you're just as
talented and obviously nowhere narrows
down he's like yeah so you can get away
with that now he couldn't but i'm sure
you'll be fine i was like yeah oh i'm
not doing that you know ty you ever hear
the story about tiger woods with john
daly john daley you know john daly grave
golfer but also like alcoholic bring him
up bring up take a look at what he looks
like he can beat anybody in golf
fatty [ __ ] gambler apparently lost 50
million dollars something crazy drink
like drink a drink before big turns but
he was a he's a party oh dude yeah
that's him right there that's oh okay by
the way not that different from when he
was playing and still playing that way i
mean just just that's pretty current
dude that's time yeah
and uh and john daly tiger woods was
kind of walking by and john goes hey
come join us and time goes i can't i got
to go work on my stroke and he said dude
like
enough with working on this you wake up
so early go to bed to [ __ ] come hang
up have a beer and tiger whiz goes hey
john you can do that i can't
i'm not good enough i have to actually
practice it was [ __ ] amazing man
whether that's true or not oh brian
guess what uh i think you're right uh
new york i went to new york i was in new
york last night for how long uh for a
day i had two pizza places yeah pizza's
pizza yeah which pizza did you go to
pizza uh i can't remember the name but i
want to do i mean
come on there's good come on that's
where you go though yeah it depends
where you went though did you go with
someone who knows new york yeah and
knows pizza because there's something
you tell me i was in
manhattan you went with frankie edgar
and i believe that because they talked
about the water the water the new jersey
dough or something makes a huge
difference yeah you said it was just
really i've had good people pretty much
everywhere though but that manure is
[ __ ] like prince street pizza is
[ __ ] great joe's pizza is great
i don't know there's a great pizza out
here
i apologize if i see him a little bit
i'm i'm a little bit my feelings my
heart's a little tender this morning
what
well
i [ __ ] were you on the road this
weekend i was where were you i was in
columbus oh yeah i had a good time
columbus funny bone always a good funny
bone always good yeah probably the best
funny bone out of that's the original
one right yeah you know i moved and i
have now there's a little i'm running a
place uh with my my lady and uh there's
a there's a um
[ __ ] uh
it's a uh
you got this i have a pond yeah okay i
it came with a pump with like koi fish
instead of two koi fish
really yeah great turtle and and my
turtle's name is hilda my kids named him
hilda hilda
it's an older name and i always think of
turtles as masculine i wanted to name my
turtle like birds
it is
and they were like they named her hilda
and so she's a cutie but the koi fish
would always steal always steals steal
her food and she's really coy anyway
she's an aquatic turtle and my kids love
her and they're always the first one
they want to see is hilda because she's
super shy and you have to be quiet well
and i've come to i've come to be
attached to hilda and my koi
yeah yeah that's it so wait do you feed
this morning
outside oh thank goodness definitely not
oh thank god stephanie tell me the
turtle died i woke up this morning [ __ ]
yeah and and hilda was on her back
turned upside down and i went why is she
turned upside down
and i went over and hilda didn't have a
head and she didn't have any feet
so something ate my [ __ ] turtle i
wonder what ate that joke that's what i
want to find out it's hard to get the
feet and head because they they go it
was so awful now i gotta tell my kids
they're gonna no no no no no no no just
buy a new turtle
but there's something that's killing
turtles now i'm gonna buy another
[ __ ] turtle
and i don't think we can delay you can
delay that whole conversation just buy a
new turtle i'm gonna buy a new turtle
you're not gonna do it but how do i
what's eating my [ __ ] turtle i assume
a raccoon i think it's a raccoon or a
possum well hustlers roll like that a
cat
it could be it could be those claws get
deep in there yeah cause they're gonna
retract it's tough to eat a turtle's
head and oh they're like there it is
that's why
that's what i have you [ __ ] raccoon
dale
they rate a turtleneck snack on fresh
hatchling turtles no could have been the
koi fish and they roll they roll deep
don't they
raccoons huh and possums oh
[ __ ] you don't want no problems
with pasta something's ugly brother they
all want to kill my [ __ ] turtle man i
wonder what got to it dude
it has to be a record you don't have any
[ __ ] dumpsters and stuff gotta be
there's not possums out that way yeah
there are you've seen them there's
possum's all over
not a snakey but this [ __ ]
chewed his head off they're trying to
have to be a raccoon
it's this other church because raccoons
got the hands yeah they have the human
hands yeah
and you know she was really shy and she
would barely come up she'd be hiding
down there and now i know why now i know
why she was just shoes
every [ __ ] night when the sun goes
down think about that a giant like could
be a possum could be a [ __ ] raccoon
could be a cat everybody wants how deep
is that little pond not deep enough yep
deep enough that raccoon was like oh i'm
going skinny dipping yeah and hilda was
probably like you know what it's a nice
night i'm just going to pop myself a
little layer catch them
that's aggressive hold him out and just
left him it's an insult to me because
you left that that turtle it just took
the head finish it like you've been
better if you thought the turtle ran
away yeah
yeah god that's [ __ ] up you just left
them there just buy a new turtle though
you know they're turtles yeah
it's a turtle and you can get it how big
was it right pets or pets were still
popping oh it was big it's a big turtle
like i give you a little pet smart i
guess i'm gonna go yeah
you got to get one that size though
that's a good turn on that size yeah and
those outdoor turtles don't [ __ ] around
it was a big one it was a big one yeah
now
i might get a [ __ ] smashing turtle
i might get let's see what happens a
little tough for the kids because
they're like oh here's greta where the
[ __ ] her name is hilda and then
yeah that you don't want to [ __ ] with it
remember that sniping turtle that i was
petting oh yeah oh what happened where
where were we at we were in
we were a cherokee nation in uh arkansas
or something like oklahoma oklahoma and
that guy left that room and started
pissing everywhere
dude how big was it oh 150 pounds he was
[ __ ] i'm not kidding and it beat you
no
it didn't the guy would lift it up and
he would put like pencils and stuff and
snap all the pencils been a phone booth
yeah i mean you got a little 200 turtles
for me but yeah it was fun grabbed a
phone book we're in the middle of
oklahoma so this turtle's far from where
the [ __ ] he's from yeah i think they
have snapping turtles in oklahoma though
the rivers out there
i think that's where they those
alligator snapping turtles there's no
joke don't do don't get one of those
what does it look like well they'll
they'll take your [ __ ] i'll take all
the all the digits oh yeah they'll take
all your digits i mean and they keep
their mouth open and anything you put in
there though
yeah yeah they're [ __ ] brutal dude i
like the i like the shirt today man i've
seen that in a hot second vintage abbott
kenny fight club yeah we should come
back out with those huh i think so
i love them um this is this is a special
fight club one that'd be a good idea
that'd be good
although we it started on abbot kinney
right yeah but when you're in manhattan
now and i'm in [ __ ] calabasas yeah
kind of far i'll stay true to the stay
true
yeah i've never been over that way you
never been abbot kenny
come on
damn jesus christ you know me i don't
get out much i gotta get you two you're
all down there but you've done uh what's
that venice uh stand up spot the
underground i've never done this on the
ground you've not done that but you've
done this well i guess that's far third
straight no longer you do that one oh
venice underground's gone no it's such a
great yeah
i mean i watched the show there coveted
kel when i first came
killed a lot of [ __ ] um how was tampa
buddy well temple was headlining his own
shows yeah really we missed him yeah
david did a hot 30.
he did a hot two gun 30. two guns is
that right and dude he lit up this black
dude in the front row oh and the black
guy kept talking i'm like dude how like
you're literally just he posted the
video of him lighting up uh dude with
the jacket in denver denver yeah dude
but in been in but in vegas this black
end front row kind of looked like seal
but not with the shitty skin right kind
of look like him and [ __ ]
as a skin bro and uh he had acne as a
young man but all the holes on his face
but uh so this guy looked like him but
handsome you know
and for a reason kept talking
oh like so david are just like talking
but not like heckling but he kept
talking like almost like one of those
hecklers that like agreed with
everything like i just told her like
[ __ ] up the punch line oh like you're
about saying like you go yeah
yeah yeah dude but dude he kept going
and i was like i wonder why the guy's
doing it and then probably it's probably
10 minutes that dave just lightened him
up because he was like this your girl
she was white he was super dark oh my
god start talking about how they have
kids and stuff
oh my god dude i don't know why then i
came out and i and right when i can't
say i went what were you thinking dude
yeah i said what do you think you're
talking during the show man he's like no
no more you learned your lesson he goes
yep what good yeah what are you doing
dude there i didn't know this no you
know paulie sure owns part of wise guys
oh i didn't know oh he lives out there
yeah dave david went to his house i
couldn't go uh because i had a headache
and uh so david went and paulie was like
playing a band and he uh dave was like
he's like a kid man he's all right now
it's time for peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches
from georgia
no he's from alabama he's such a
character yeah dave was like what in the
[ __ ] yeah what a character
he's a great guy man i love paul oh he's
such a good person yeah his next door
neighbors uh uh nicholas cage really i
like dude i'll come over if nicholas
cage is there yeah he's like i don't
think he's around buddy
buddy he's a special dude man he's a
really special dude apparently his
mother used to let him mitzy short would
let him cry
and uh where's the baby go get him you
know she's like now you'll learn how to
deal with a tough audience
we were taught we were talking about
that like the way you know paulie's
great human being like caring like just
a good person but it's like when you
think about the way he was brought up
and his mom you know obviously having
sex with the comedians and there's it's
just this this turmoil and the guys that
used to babysit him and it's just like
he's lucky he turned out the way he did
yeah man
but like there was a guy in the green
room and uh he was this young kid and he
was like who's that because we got
pictures with him i posted a picture of
paulie and he's like who's i'm like
probably sure he's like oh damn i got
that when were you born yeah he's all i
i was like i was born i think he said
1999 2000 or something like that yeah
people so he's like 21 i'd go oh dude
yeah in the 90s
he was the [ __ ] super famous yeah man
i worked with him on mad tv when he was
at the house
mtv spring break and then he did encino
mancino
like he was always really cool though we
had scenes together i remember in 1996 i
did a scene with paulie he still sells
out man
he says some really nice stuff to me
because he hasn't seen me do stand-up
since
probably just four years ago at the
commission yeah wow and so he said he
was he was a buddy i'm mistaken yeah he
was [ __ ] he was buddy i was your
friend he was like uh i was at some of
your early spots at the comedy store
he's like and you're the first headliner
here i'm gonna stay for your show he's
like don't be nervous buddy no and i was
like yeah i'm fine dude and then yeah he
said some really really nice stuff
that's so cool in the army now i
remember that one dude he was huge yeah
how many movies he's done so many
that's a good career right there oh my
god especially think about what he came
from man right now uh stories that we
should get them on here yeah stories
i've always i've been talking to him for
years about coming on yeah i was trying
to help him out with his podcast he was
gonna do this podcast out of the house
it's a bit of a [ __ ] show but
oh he should come on here at least yeah
he has some great stories yeah he's he's
got amazing stories he got on
he did a monologue on mad tv
and
he
he started by going i'm polly sure loser
anyway and he and he started talking
about how his mom
brought a man in
to the house and it was thanksgiving and
she was dating him and how i think the
man kind of raised a hand to his mom and
how they got in a fight
it was the he was crushing the room
uh-huh and here's what was amazing about
it it was all true true he was just
telling the story
but his delivery is just
with it oh dude but it was all true we
just grew up around greatness so you
gotta figure yeah but that was my one of
my lessons in in
comedy was i was like this guy's
actually doing a dramatic monologue
about a traumatic event when he was a
kid yeah and chris making it funny and i
was like that's really interesting
yeah so you would like vegas you know
keith don't [ __ ] around keith wise guys
it's such a good club great guy yeah
yeah man i want to go you're such an
intimate like an old school yeah old
school room hard to find that in vegas
well that's what why keith did he's like
this kept for the locals he's like like
because it's off the strip it's in the
store it's in the art district by the
stratosphere which is super hoody but
that one street there's like a brewery
across like it's all brand new really
everything's new it's not downtown not
old downtown no it's our district it's
like between downtown and the
stratosphere oh okay yeah it was really
nice man yeah it was just a really
really tough good club yeah great club
great that's amazing yeah keith doesn't
as he said he's bringing you i think
to salt lake city yes uh yeah i'll be in
salt lake city and i got an offer for
vegas so i'll be doing yeah
this weekend you're like vegas this
weekend thursday friday saturday if you
need me you know where i'll be right
at your house finding churches i'll be
at at your house murdering turtles
you murdered that turtle
uh boobies
dudes movies
now can we change the way we change the
name
of maryland places called magoobies and
i don't know what to do
timonium it's an hour and ten minutes
outside of washington dc that's all i
know yeah and i'll be flying into dc and
may try to drive he's trying to get to
baltimore
well that's that's another [ __ ]
because you gotta take two planes and
you'll get now you gotta be careful now
flying southwest because yesterday oh
yeah get to the airport and you know i
use claire and the lady goes uh you know
nice blacklight she goes honey
you check of your flight still going out
and you know
i don't know social media i'm like
well yeah they get my boarding pass
you're like oh you have no idea what's
going on like no
do you not realize how dead is in here
i'm like
or it's early she's like no no she goes
no no oh that's right 500 flights were
canceled from southwest and i go ah [ __ ]
what happened she has vaccines demand
mandatory vaccines so a bunch of pilots
and people quit so they had to cancel
the flight she goes but honey you're
going to hear them tell you that's the
weather she was how was the weather when
came here i go i mean
fine yeah she goes
that's what it is
but they're not they're they don't want
that message out there oh my god but
that's all it is the all the pilots and
the stewardess stuff don't want to still
gotta wear masks even though your
vaccine you you're still gonna win that
yeah i was telling chin how crazy is so
i hate uh casinos it's triggering for me
because the only time i was in casinos
was under high pressure situations when
i was fighting so my brother beg you
know he you know jay he wants to [ __ ]
do something like a terse so you want to
go bet on games at the mandalay bay so
he convinced solves to go there we go
there and
so in vegas it's not like yellow you can
go into stores and everything without a
mask no one says anything we don't i
don't touch them as sometimes there we
go in the casino and uh i see a bunch of
people in mass i'm like you know i don't
give a [ __ ] if that's what you wanna do
do your thing but then i would see
people with the mouse but just pulled
down but they had cigarettes in their
mouth smoking
smoking right and so i was like oh
that's weird you can smoke in here i
thought you couldn't smoke but you can
and i'm allergic to smokes that's fun so
uh this guy security crap comes up and
goes hey my man you know it's me and my
squad so we look like [ __ ] big pun in
the terror squad we're all big
[ __ ] i mean look david is 300 pounds
jay's giant yeah you know and then you
got justin just skinny guy but we're all
huge
and he goes my man you got to put a mask
on i go inside the casino yeah i go that
guy's not wearing any smoke serious yeah
but he's smoking
and i go
what and he starts laughing when you're
when you're gambling you have to have a
mask on so listen so you have to have a
mask on if you if you're doing anything
but smoking if you're smoking you'll
have to mask on and so i tell the guy go
and he goes here's i'm with me i'm
[ __ ] sick around this thing hopefully
it ends soon and i said dude so let me
get straight if i smoke a cigarette and
get cancer and blow in your face and
you're getting cancer we know for a fact
this is causing cancer i can walk around
and smoke cigarettes because yeah that's
right and i go how crazy is this he goes
dude i wish i had a better explanation
and then i said well if i go to the
convenience store and there's one yeah
and i buy the crew cigarettes i can just
walk around with cigarettes matthew goes
that's what i would do
i'm like whoa
and when when
do we get to lose these masks it's going
on two years now as your daddy found you
yeah ask your daddy ask your daughter he
has a documentary coming on national
geographic
for what yeah interesting you just had
one come out on netflix yeah yeah yeah
oh they made it so only the criticis
critics can review it except for imdb
you go to imdb it they rip them apart
it's like
97 on rotten tomatoes imdb is like 1.9
out of 10. they keep overreaching
why are they making documentaries about
them do you see it do you see
unemployment he wants to be famous you
see the unemployment in red states
versus blue states you see
no ben shapiro was talking about that's
very interesting say what you will about
republican democrat i got i'm i'm a
moderate but i know where you're at but
[ __ ] it's unbelievable how
unemployment in blue states is so high
and and this is according to shapiro's
you know
trail smart guys
so i think that what's going to happen
is this overreach and the fact that the
democratic party's been hijacked by the
far left and all this math stuff is
going to it's going to still work out
for us in the end oh yeah they're going
to pay a price yeah
now tampa never did yeah
i'll be in naples now i'll be in naples
november 11th to the 14th
yeah great can i wait let's take a break
from chat with the boys because with
today's low interest rates it's a great
time to refinance your student loans
aren't you sick of them earnest offers
low rate student loan refinancing and
you can check your rate risk-free in
just two months with earnest you get
flexible payments and you pick your loan
terms all right by refinancing you can
reduce your loan term save money and
combine multiple loans onto one simple
monthly payment isn't time stop feeling
overwhelmed by your student debt ernest
is offering you 500 kids fans 100 cash
bonus
refinance your student debt at
earnest.com fighter
conditions apply
that's earnest.com fighter refinance
your student loan not available in all
states terminal conditions apply visit
earnest.com for more details terms
condition supply earn a student loan
refinancing made by earnest operations
llc and mls number one two zero four
nine one seven california financing law
license number six zero five four seven
eight eight fifty three five mission
street san francisco california 94105
visit earnest.com
licenses for full list of licenses
you know i get a lot of questions about
cbd and cbd isn't what you feel it's
about what you don't feel how about
stress anxiety pain we can help out with
all that and feels is a better way to
feel better feels is a premium cbd that
will help you keep your head clear and
feel your best it's hassle free
delivered directly to your door cbd
naturally helps reduce stress anxiety
pain sleepiness there's no hangover
addictions none of that stuff i use it
every day every night my kiddos use it
it's super safe but you gotta trust your
cbd
uh company man that's where feels comes
to place feels offers free cbd hotline
to help you guide your personal
experience so that you find your perfect
dose
all right start feeling better with feel
cbd
become a member today by going to
feels.com
dot com slash fighter you get 50 off
your first order with free shipping
fields dot com slash fighter um when i
was there with my boy who owns the
restaurant right down the street okay oh
yeah yumi are the same we like food yeah
this dude his name's nick right uh
italian dude yeah i think it's nick dude
yeah the best restaurant in naples is
that right fresh brazilian
like i'm all over it please do it oh my
god that was amazing the best food
remember the restaurant's name i'm
texting the guy
oh he's from new york he's italian he's
a fan of course he's yeah italian guy in
new york
aggressive he's got like a good
experience it was like 1400 bucks dude
you don't have to keep confidence just
get the [ __ ] out of it get the [ __ ] out
i go please take my car dude you fed us
every night we've been here these prices
are expensive you get the [ __ ] out of it
and then he took they took this whiskey
off the off the bar like some high shelf
whiskey i forget what it is and he was
like i saved this dress for you i knew
you're coming just for you and some guy
goes the [ __ ] met some older ghosts dude
what the [ __ ] i was trying to buy a
drink of that and it's it's on your
table and they get and the owner goes
get the [ __ ] out of here
i go dude you can sell him my kind of
guy oh he's not everybody what the [ __ ]
you doing what are you doing when i went
there during covet during covet like the
height of tampa
nobody was wearing a mask the old people
were like [ __ ] you like there's a lot of
old people in the audience yeah i was
like jesus christ and it was before the
vaccine they were like yeah defiant yeah
naples is beautiful it's beautiful uh
now
speaking of casinos and all that yeah
i invested for you i did some i did some
things
you invested in
airbnb we were talking about here i
bought you with some nfts oh no let me
let me explain the old man trying to
stick his beak in some nfts i bought you
daddy's dry beak i bought you some no
fun toads i might give you some too what
is it i might give everybody
some well they can't butter
well
no fun toads so no fun so this is the
genesis of it when i went to france my
buddy came to join me my buddy mark and
he goes do you think about mnfts no you
guys well
you know there are these images that you
can trade they're like trading cards on
the digital trading card and he goes i
bought an ape because i was asking him
you told us
he bought an eight
go to um
go to [ __ ]
nft apes go ahead he bought an ape now
when they released these apes
they were 250 dollars they were in eath
you buy them in oh they're like um uh uh
what is it called ethereum yeah there
you go that's it yeah he bought one just
one and you just have the image on your
phone right is that what you said yeah
that's all now now uh it's yours now
what do you do you just put on your
phone now his ape and i i remember he
bought it and he bought it at the time
for like six grand and i was just like
you know these used to be free they were
uh the first one of the first nfts on
the platform and so a lot of people had
like hundreds of those oh yeah now hold
on so let me let me show so so i i
remember i go six thousand dollars i was
like i looked at him like this i was
like well you're crazy well they're a
hundred and the cheapest one is 140 000
right now the cheapest one so his age
now is worth something like 200 grand
now the original ape called board ape
yacht club has
542 million in lifetime sales thank you
to an 700 traders yeah please and please
hold then there's cool cats and there's
crypto pumps one piece sold for 69
million dollars is this like the
stylings of like trading cards hold on
so so just please so then there's crypto
punks which the cheapest one is 393
crypto punks crypto punks it's a [ __ ]
weird thing 393 000 hold on it's a it
they trade them back and forth
and they gave those out i believe for
free initially okay now then they went
came up with cryptos cryptos right now
toad yeah right now cryptos are 60 grand
that's what you bought him so the guy i
know i know a guy
who's launching no fun toads with some
real people yes like some you know now i
don't know anything about this
it's written i just want to make some
money holy [ __ ] but 1.6 million well
there you go for that that topic can you
print it out and put on your wall dude
it's is that an old man question i don't
know
i don't know what to do but i don't know
um here's what happened with brian
that's my agent sorry guys
sorry so this is what happened with uh
with good old bri yeah uh so i i know
some people and they're launching no fun
toads on tuesday well tomorrow
i i took the liberty and you have to pay
me for my price
pay the original price yeah how much do
you pay for them well they're right now
i think they go for about 140 bucks a
total how many did you buy now daddy may
have had daddy may have gotten in on the
ground floor and by the way i'm not
telling anybody about [ __ ] toads
no who knows i'm not pitching nfts i
just i've never done i've never invested
you saw how much you're very
conservative yeah you saw how much i
just think this i know some people that
are really balls deep in it and they say
buy toes you'll go broke if you're like
me and you just decide to go into it
that's about it i'm hitching on to
people you only put 140 bucks in i'm i'm
hitching onto people that know how to do
you bought more than one toad oh i
bought us
i got i got some i got i got some toads
i got a sip of dick chocolate you you
want what you do no fun toads i go to go
to no fun tone i want to go to cryptos
and then go to no fun toad
go to cryptosphere.com
what's your first book sounds like
crypto just lost seven
as they were explaining this [ __ ] to me
i was like dude there's a marketplace
out there that i know nothing about the
difference between ethereum and crypto
uh and and uh bitcoin is so weird i
don't know any of this stuff
and um
but you're dipping your toad in it
i just think we may as well
like that brian yeah open seas is the
marketplace no i think it's open seas
bubba opens yeah like the sea yeah open
seas
there it is dot com yeah
and that's where you can buy
i don't know
oh cool that's a [ __ ] uh yeah
what do you
think there's a marketplace where they
buy all the stuff i have no idea yeah
you don't know the website there there
it is
oh there it is look at that
there is a map there is a coastal
economy hey you might turn those crypto
toads into
i don't know two hundred thousand
couldn't we just make our own crypto
well finally here's what i think we're
going to make we're the first comics to
be talking about this maybe that's worth
something i was like maybe
i don't think we're the first kids look
at how much those go those are 60 grand
those are crypto just that yeah and what
are we going to do with that we're
launching we're launching it looks like
oh geez nintendo i know we're not i mean
i don't have anything to do with it but
i i'm buying something so we're going
well now we're going to both owners one
of them is that seven grand for what
wait i can't tell what that is
dude
and you just get that thing yeah
yeah dude do you show your friend they
trade them there's a whole market that's
what i'll say it's like so it's like
trading cards it's
so you guys know all about this i don't
know a little bit about it i was okay is
it like trading cards though i knew yeah
isn't stevie trying to get into it oh
yeah stevie has quite a few right now he
is obsessed with his yakuza cat that's
the next big thing yakuza
what did they originally go for
so i think the floor price is fairly low
when you got it
on the rise well you should share this
is crazy
go to
nofunto.com
no fun toad no fun toads.com toads or
toad
toad i think it really does seem like a
new age like trading card toad chin i
know
[Music]
let's see
nope
is it all one word
no fun
here it is that's what i bought us
well he's cute they're cute and they're
all so they so the computer
generates random ones you get random
ones you can't choose yeah and you can't
get you have to
you can't choose them ethereum is so
interesting that way ethereum is like
they're all these computers right and
they're talking to each other
and the computers create an image
that can't be replicated that's that's
how that works you're the original owner
yes it's like an art piece yeah there's
only one so you have to think how much
that so the value of the dollar is if
there's only one michael jordan rookie
card it's like millions of dollars okay
the value of the dollar is kind of like
as it's like it's it's transfer value so
as it's traded over the uh over you know
overseas with different currencies uh uh
tax revenue gdp
it's all these different factors that
give you the i'm saying that that's
yeah people are deciding okay it's worth
something yeah it's all [ __ ] weird
it's insane
if you bought bitcoin in 2013. that's
stupid to say though because if i bought
apple in 90 in 1989 we'd be billionaires
and i'm not it's not my i'm not into
this i'm not i'm not in stocks or any of
that stuff i've smarted people that deal
with all that
what if a week i bet eventually i would
need to learn the [ __ ] what if it weaved
now i'm like hey guys i quit i'm a
billionaire
five million dollars hey guys here's a
toad it's worth 500 million dollars if
that happens dude i'm selling all my
toads i'm not sitting on them no yeah
yeah i don't know just get rid of it
i have no idea how long it's going to
last let's sell them obviously
immediately yeah
if they go we'll still do the show but
it'll probably last a while huh we're
we'll replace jim with an actual toad
you have to wear a no fun toad costume
if i get a billion dollars yeah i'll do
it a billion that's a lot a million then
a million
500k and you dressed as a toad every day
well the ape guys made 900 million
dollars in eight minutes apparently when
they launched their second phase of them
i don't know what to say about this
i have no idea i don't trust you but and
i don't trust that number and i don't
trust what i just don't know anything
sounds like a ponzi scheme but i'm in
i think that nft because you can see the
money from it kind of
yeah well you can see it but that only
means people are willing to that's what
the that's the
the value he said it's home you got 100
grand two hundred grand no yeah he
bought it he bought it hey what were you
doing and you so you flew from tampa
to from tampa to new york just for one
night yeah just for what uh to see my
homies play in their home
home state where their band came up and
uh is that the video sentence on stage
yeah yeah yeah video channel
[ __ ] man
chappelle was lit as [ __ ] how are you
not drunk at this thing i don't know you
got after it what do you see him on
stage i saw it
i saw it inside i was impressed
this one yeah
i was too lit
now do you do they tell you what songs
you come out to before yeah yeah i knew
what i was singing
but
i've never done it like this before
who's the guy hanging on i don't know
it's just random people oh they just
jump on stage and hang on yeah that's
like the thing they do you push them
back uh yeah how's the security next
jump though
oh watch right here
[Music]
it's so cool
if you hit the next video you're gonna
see the crowd from tampa they were lit
so you did a show after that uh no that
i flew
after that show i flew to new york
you fly out now you flew in the morning
uh the early that morning
and you flew from that was it that was a
that was a great weekend yeah it looks
good dude yeah flew from new york to
here
yeah i flew i left uh 6 am this morning
i'm out of it
i'm out of it that's why that's why not
drinking pays off for you oh yeah i i
think yeah i think if i drink there's no
way i ate because this fuku burger place
the owner came and you know told us what
to get i had so much sodium in my face
you got swollen dude i couldn't see i
was like a sharpay i could my my face
was so swollen from sodium i could not
see are they like big burgers yeah
pull it up oh they're nice
burger oh jade two of them [ __ ] fat
jay's following them now too
jay's fault
it's instagram they have a uh
cat katsuwa ketsu ketsu katsu katsu uh
akatsu burger uh chicken
spicy chicken
it's nice
it has like this japanese hot sauce on
it wow it was nice wow there's no way i
could do it and the fries have gravy on
them jake two of those and the gravy
fries like and then [ __ ]
yeah that'll get to you i can't yeah i
couldn't do that the number two is what
they're known for it's egg with some
sort of seaweed on it
like egg and beef
tobacco i went with number one the
number six is delicious the crispy
chicken sandwich oh my god dude i mean
but i two of them my face
my fiance um you know when she's
something her face she blows up into a
balloon i'm like yeah that's how it was
you look like a balloon right now it's
the sodium
hey that's tighten this [ __ ] up did you
watch
the fight dude so we had it on in the
back yeah and uh i told dave and my kate
go longer so i can watch this [ __ ]
fight yeah so he did like 30 minutes
it was but that was one of the guys i
watched
like 30 and change and he gets off like
[ __ ] so i saw rounds one through four
then i left and then came back the fight
was over and i was like i'll be able to
watch in the back and then of course
when you do meet and greets be like dude
you see what happened to wilder i'm like
no what happened
you just did you watch it yeah you just
realized that tyson fury's just better
as a boxer that was an amazing fight you
can't fight somebody who's that good and
they figure you out they they figure you
out right i don't know it's that it was
more i think it was more like fear came
in super heavy which was alarming at
first but his game plan was like beat
him up wear him out then knock him out
later in the rounds which he did yeah
um i don't know if it's very fury
figuring them out i just feel just
tougher man because that fight got
sloppy
but i think what i mean is that i feel
like fury always has a lot of things to
do right and he's got a lot of different
like punches and i think wilder did that
low jab then he would do like he came in
yeah you could tell like it made sense
to go that new camp he looked great as
soon as he got the door he got tired you
know more about this why did he stop
doing that why did he stop going to the
bottom it's not it's not in his
it's just not in that's not his the way
he's wired yeah you can train for that
yeah as soon as you get hit which he did
early on remember he he got clipped into
the first round my right hand yes and he
got clipped again back in the head too
and then he got clipped again and then
you just go back to what you're good at
you go to your happy place which is and
then he needs d for his knockouts
there's a sweet spot he needs distance
so
that first and second round when he had
uh
fury going back i was like oh this is
perfect because he and land that
knockout shot but as soon as wilder felt
this i'm sorry fury fell to power and
started closing the gap then it's tough
because wilder doesn't have the tools to
throw combos inside he doesn't get you
against ropes throw combos that's dirty
so once it closed and he's the heavier
guy he's just trying to wear him out but
also when he knocked him down twice i
was like oh [ __ ] yeah also when you're
close with a guy that big and he's got
he's really good dirty boxer like
uppercuts elbow and you getting you in
position
he's good at everything yeah
yeah that's what i mean by my biggest
key on that i said this on below the
belt the biggest marker if you're like a
boxing like boxing head the biggest
marker was uh wilder's footwork it's
real sloppy it wasn't there oh it wasn't
there yeah and you're not going to beat
fury doing that it's not not as good
well fury even said he was like you know
he had nothing but nice things to say
after the fight and he's like he's a
great fighter man he's just second best
like he's just yeah i always say he's
the second best fighter in the world i'm
the best true that's what it is it's
really true what why and the people that
say it's the greatest trilogy of all
time i don't agree with that no i don't
know because they they fought me and
chin looked up they fought 30 rounds
fury probably won 24 to 30. agreed
why why do you think wilder just left
like that
uh
he doesn't know how to deal with loss he
i mean he's had some losses in his life
like his personal life but he's never
had lost his professional career like
where you think about it like fury the
first one was a draw so you know that
was whatever yeah second when he got
absolutely annihilated but he's never
had to deal with the loss so things like
he cheated which we know is not true oh
it was the suit i was tired so he makes
all these excuses but remember he's
never handled a loss before so that was
just a bad look yeah [ __ ] dude they lose
the fury again and that was like his
entire career like like livelihood was
riding on it you could tell how bad he
wanted it yeah yeah yeah i think he'll
tough while he's so tough so he stuffed
that his eyes were both lips bleeding
and then even when you look at the combo
the ending combo he's getting hit but he
has such a fighter's heart he refused to
go down he had to turn the lights off
for him to go down yeah so like you want
it so bad so i just don't he has no
experience on how to handle loss yeah
too much
i think and i i don't think it's he's
not a bad person diana is a great human
being i just don't think he has any
experience in losing he just doesn't
does he fight joshua next does he no
joshua's fighting uh using again yep
mandatory fury will wait for that if he
doesn't want to wait to fight dillian
white and white has a fight again so i
watched joshua fight dylan white if
joshua fights
usyk the way he fought dylan white
joshua was going to win that fight
joshua when he really wants it and he
uses his strength and just starts
brawling good luck
good luck because he's [ __ ] dylan
catch him on that fight savage yeah no
he knocked he knocked dylan white out in
that fight i know but
dylan
dylan white's a monster but yeah but i
think out of the four big boys so you
look at wilder usyk fury and joshua
wilder usyk and fury i don't question
why they're in the game at all yeah
joshua question
is in just his heart i mean yeah
now i don't think he'd be willing to do
what
deonte water do to get our respect
to and and get knocked down that fight
like wilder like they were asking his
coach like hey did he tell you guys make
sure you don't throw in the towel and
the coach was like we've never really
had that convo but we know yeah like we
know like he always says let me go out
on my shield no matter [ __ ] what
that's why i fired that last camp yeah
he's like always let me grab my shield
no matter what dude this isn't your
decision it's mine yeah okay and they're
like we knew it so wow
because
it'd be i think if joshua decides that
he has to win if joshua decides
he's a better boxer god
i think if he did if he fought
tyson fury the way he fought
uh
never no
i don't know man it doesn't beat fear
inside it's gonna be a worse inside that
could be a person really
but inside fighting i think jerry's
gonna go inside on him he's gonna stay
outside and pick him apart his foot
works too good really and and joshua
gets hit he gets hit clams up like
there can be a worse matchup for joshua
haley no
fury's number one
number one by far what about fury or is
it too small for him too small music's
too small but that's the most
interesting fight stylist because usig
as far as technical wise is better than
fury yeah but fury fear the size and
yeah i don't know just too much i i
would never bet against fury not me
either i would never be how about how
about david luke's brother so david got
a
he was with wilder's entourage and they
gave him a backstage pass to go into the
fight oh [ __ ] so who's alright i'm sorry
just dude david lucas gave his little
brother flew out from l.a cause he's
like hey i'll be on stage i'm not gonna
make it do you want
literally you're gonna walk with wilder
that's [ __ ] amazing so he's like yeah
say less flew out there paid his weight
you know he's a young kid don't have
money spends all his money to get out
there
and then david calls the guy the night
of the fight because he's he was in our
green room he's like i'm about to go to
the fight man but we're like oh it'd be
fun man and then david goes dude guess
what my the pass is my name on it we
can't switch the names so you can't go
so i was like here's the thing david's
little brother so i know you're
expecting to watch the fight with wilder
and be like ringside you're watching the
green room now on illegal streaming cell
thoughts right i could have told you
that yeah i could have told you and i
said i'm so sorry now my ex you're like
nice stuff fun man i'm like i'm sure i'm
sure and this is heartbreaking for you
yeah i think it's going to be so bright
if you want nachos or chicken tenders
because club food so if you want any of
that order all you want buddy no
that's so he's such a nice kid though i
know he's so nice oh he's really cool
my ex
she uh she i think she's dating a
wealthy man uh and she uh she just hit
me with i'm at the fight and she goes um
what's the splatter zone
and i'm like huh i got a text she's she
ringside she goes i go what she goes i
how what is this
splatters ringside and she [ __ ] sends
me a video she's literally she can touch
those guys and now i'm like now you know
i'm watching a fight i'm like my ex is
with some you know billionaire
thank god it's great it's all good
yeah no dude it's better this way but
she was building this
because she's she's such a smart ass is
this good are these seats
she just sends me a video and i can hear
her going whoa go fury she doesn't even
know and i'm like you [ __ ] i don't
know knowing that everybody wants to be
so [ __ ] funny is this good i don't
know if these seats are good
dude we gotta have a talk with justin
his cell phone use i was like dude do
you have any ideas not stop yeah i go do
you get a thing on your you know
everyone's cell phones like tell you how
long you've been on it he goes yeah yeah
18 hours a day 18. what
who are with my opener justin that's why
he's always he's done he's always needed
a charger oh he always needs
a gucci satchel and he has a charger in
the satchel but we're walking down like
a busy street in vegas and he's on
instagram flipping like this and jay
goes but he's like slow and i'm like
we're just gonna have to leave him dude
i'm like justin dude you gotta get off
your phone be in the moment
and then you know then keith is in there
talking green yeah and justin's on his
phone i'm like bro you want to work for
that guy yeah get off your phone yeah
damn
yeah he is on his phone a lot and when
we talk to him and then i go you know
the the whole thing with facebook came
out and we know how addicting instagram
is and yeah what it does to children
stuff like that like you know you like
you're a grown man think about dick
you're out of your funnies yeah i'm
addicted think about it you
now you're a grown man and you have
issues with it think about the younger
generation dude they're so [ __ ]
because i i constantly tell them all the
time i'm like dude we could be doing
iraq and you would have no clue where
that's true
your screen's the same wherever you're
at he does write me back the fastest out
of anyone yeah you miss [ __ ] like
what
i thought what i told him i said if you
put half the effort into your stand up
that you do on your phone dude you're
headlining forget it you should put the
halfway just funny and smart yeah so if
you just put half the effort that you're
doing whatever you're doing yeah
into writing or whatever the [ __ ] you
want to get done
yeah i don't think i know anyone that's
on the phone as much as
and finally even jay got fed up with it
he's like dude what are we i mean he's
on the phone that's so funny yeah he's a
grown man he's just got to chill i miss
my turtle man
that's what that's what i don't know how
much
oh yeah
seven calories
yeah you know kevin hart if you go with
him there's no phones he'll be in the
moment really oh if i was his crew if i
was more famous i'd do the exactly kevin
kevin's crew i mean
there's i don't know yeah because we're
all hanging it's all chill like you know
yeah i mean yeah i don't know just don't
need to really be on it you know
30 bucks to 200. depending on the
species
i'm buying something
i don't know where you can catch one but
you don't want to get one of the little
[ __ ] redneck ones like the petsmart
don't go like a real
amphibian sore off ventura they have
like lizards and crocodiles on the cover
you're like a real [ __ ] turtle dude i
need a real turtle but i want a [ __ ] i
need a turtle i need something else
that's going to keep those [ __ ]
raccoons away
like a snapping turtle
or a [ __ ] dog the raccoon's got hands
man yeah they do yeah pluck them right
out they'll just i like they don't want
that [ __ ] great i don't want one of
those tortoises live like what about
that that's not bad no i want i want to
[ __ ] um oh i have to get it's got to
be aquatic it's got to live with my koi
but then he'll probably die too yeah
especially it gets cold at night but
this [ __ ] why didn't they eat
the fish this turtle has been around for
years it's lived in that pond forever
and it just died when you moved in yeah
and this [ __ ] raccoon decided like it
was gonna and i was feeding it
everywhere hey do you think he's a
homeless man turtle suit
no but they always hit the head unless
it's like that's the crunchy part unless
they're into magic spells that's that it
the red eared slider that's what i had
that's what oh that's my that's my girl
skeptical turtle it is super skeptical
looking [ __ ] raccoon yep
sold in stores only you can't order
online huh i guarantee it's a raccoon i
guarantee i don't know i think it i
think no i think he's a human
i think a homeless guy killed your
[ __ ] turtle well you ever seen that
raccoon go after that lizard catch that
lizard yeah a big lizard
they i mean
they can do that [ __ ] out there kill you
a lot of [ __ ] to kill your turtle man
yeah man it's weird he's been alive this
long and then you move into the guys so
i think he's at home with you maybe it's
someone sending you a message do you
think did they ride on the turtle yeah
they wrote they wrote
you're next yes
that's so weird yeah
no it said brian with a circle around
and a big line across across yeah yeah
what if it's one of our buddies playing
a joke interesting well that's a
horrible joke to cut a turtle's head off
pretty savvy rogan says his dog got
eaten by a mountain lion in colorado
that would be awful to come and come out
and see your dog all messed up do we
believe that story
i don't know
[Laughter]
you ever see there's a there's an uh a
lodge in africa you know where it's a
high-end safari lodge you know and they
they have amazing food and it's like
yeah
like four seasons so far
chin take a look a bunch of wild dogs
chased at the middle of the night
everybody's asleep
oh yeah there's that kudu
into the lobby and it was a bloody scene
take a look at it
you ever seen this all the guests came
down they were like it is me oh
they annihilated look at that [ __ ] there
you go
there you go was it those spotted wild
dogs like that yeah they look like
little baby hyenas yeah they don't play
around there that says hyenas
that that those hyenas jesus christ they
have they actually have a stronger uh
bite than the lion oh yeah oh dude they
crack hippo oh yeah they're gnarly as
[ __ ] that thing proud thought he was
safe running the [ __ ] hotel lobby and
those those hyenas said oh you think
you're saving babies do you think we
give a [ __ ] about this four seasons
we're gonna eat you balls first dude
that's right we're gonna eat you in
front of these rich white people maybe
they didn't give these people to pay for
vip we're gonna eat you [ __ ] let's
leave our mark yeah it's called leaving
our mark hey rich white people enjoy
this oh yeah they eat ass first yeah yep
oh yeah they go ass first do you know
why ryan do i know why they didn't ask
uh because uh
the animal has the ability to attack
from head head-on so they don't like to
go head-on so they just go from the ass
yeah they get your balls doing that yeah
they'll rip them balls animals
yeah sometimes they buck them super hard
let me pee before we do current events
guys piss hard
piss hard and piss america
[Music]
let that hog out and let it drip you
know what i'm saying
got another picture of brian's dick this
weekend
i watched so many videos of that those
spotted dogs because i just uh they're
so but you know why they eat so
aggressive like that it's because
yeah the lions steal their food a lot so
they just like try to eat as fast as
they can you're telling me that's what's
wild
yeah i love this teacher dude i know a
lot about these things i love your
nature we're working on our own show on
[ __ ] national geographic dude i've
always wanted to do a tv show i pitched
it i want to do a show
where comedians you watch nature shows
and comedians dub in the voices of what
the animals would be saying
but it's hard to do it's i see a lot of
seasons with that yeah it's tough yeah
you know who kills it at that tony baker
yeah somebody does that right tony baker
he does a lot of them but it's not like
it's not necessarily like nature nature
stuff it's more like just any animal
know if he kills it good but yeah well
he
he has somebody did you watch uh i know
you don't watch football but did you
watch any football this week yes i did
did you see the chargers was browns i
did that's 49 to [ __ ]
48 or something it was not the best game
i've ever seen wow they couldn't stop
each other cheers not herbert for the
chargers dude
who's the baller chargers did wow such a
good it's such a high scoring game in
the nfl not those and i did watch a
football game i watched alabama versus
uh they lost yeah yeah should they just
give tampa the super bowl trophy or
i mean
it's gonna is it is it gonna be tampa
is it gonna be tampa green bay who's
gonna be the bills are good bells are
good bills are really good well but the
bill's lost to the steelers yeah but
they just beat the show the chiefs last
night beat the cheater
chiefs are i mean uh
cardinals undefeated their defense skip
but uh the number one team in nfl's like
on the rankings the bills is it really
yeah bill's mafia i take pride in that
because i played three seconds
[Laughter]
all right here's the first one
so a 31 year old man jumped from a
building in new jersey from the ninth
floor he landed on a parked bmw trying
to commit suicide yeah he's trying to
commit suicide dude
so the car broke his fall just like the
movies but then there's a picture of him
just like he's out of it he's just like
you can't watch it is his face all
messed up no not at all no his face
looks normal no he just broke his arm
dude you know what he just broke his arm
yeah pretty crazy how the [ __ ] bmw broke
his [ __ ] fall oh my god he dropped
how far
uh nine stories five stories imagine
that being your car though you come
outside yeah insurance there's gotta be
a better way to kill yourself that's
just there is there is and a guy did it
this there that's him that's him oh my
god he had a mask on why would you jump
yeah he had a mask oh
god yes he did and oh my god you don't
want to get covered on the way down yeah
dude
the poor guy first of all but also i'm
glad he's alive and also only bro
that shows you that god was like hey
dude not your turn yeah come on that's
incredible now on a saturn note a guy
commits suicide this weekend jumping off
the stratosphere i don't know if you've
seen how high that is but i don't know
the stratosphere what is that it's the
biggest needle in vegas it's but it's
the tallest building in vegas okay yeah
you jump from there now that you're not
going to bounce off the w is not going
to help you with that
no
what a scary way to go how did it get so
scary well you can you can get up there
because they have all the rides and
stuff and he's like oh let me see the
road coaster see on the other side oh
or is this
tuesday night
they were talking about it uh there
all the employees like do you see the
guy jumped off the stratosphere i sure
didn't
now that um you know i can survive that
one it is high high there has to be a
better way to go than that because that
is uh
really high up
um
yeah that's that's dark anyways it has a
roller coaster on it doesn't it yeah
i don't [ __ ] with it listen i stay as
far as from the stratosphere and see in
a circus circus as possible
oh sir
jordan pearson was talking to his
daughter who she suffered from
depression and she had uh really bad
arthritis and she went she said no she
said uh she said she said uh
what is it like and she said well you
know when my dog died it was my dog you
know and and i was so sad and he said so
that's kind of what it's like all the
time and she goes it's much worse than
that yeah much worse
it's like oh okay yeah
you know oh wow that's his daughter she
looks great man she's had her she's
smart too she has more kid you know
damn that's jordan peterson's dog yeah
she's very pretty good damn
well
halloween's coming
all right well well
what can you do very well i love it
lobster
lady with crawl clothes what else yet
jen alrighty this right here
so woody harrelson got into a fight with
a photographer because he was at a
watergate hotel with his daughter i
believe they were on the rooftop bar
and there was a drunk guy taking photos
of him and his daughter from afar he was
a little belligerent so woody harrelson
approached him said hey can you please
stop taking pictures of my daughter and
i and can you actually delete the photos
from your phone like i'm just trying to
spend time with mike
uh he has a few kids uh three daughters
i believe they don't say which one it
was i think the youngest is 15 and then
the eldest is 28.
but it was one of his daughters the guy
was belligerent and woody harrelson
claims that he actually tried to lunge
at him and was aiming for his neck
training
possessed and woody punched him okay so
now there are charges what's not to love
about woody harris one of the best
but this is my thing
this is my thing with the guy taking the
picture what do you can do with those
pictures dude yeah you said hey dude
check out what he's doing with his
daughter well they try to sell them
actually it's what they do they sell
them to bubba i bet you that guy wasn't
selling it no he sent his friend
he was yeah he was because he was just
drunk
he's a douchebag hear what happened to
uh uh shane gillis no he's thought we
talking about hecklers and schultz if
there's a heckler will just shut the
show down and kick you out uh you know
crystal ease do it and then joe coy same
thing he'll go stop the show lights on
get them out
and then schultz goes i kick the whole
row out
yeah he goes if you're even associated
with them and you didn't have the
mindset that they ruin the show you're
part of the prom you're out too so if
one person the whole group goes that's
how schultzy does it yeah which is fine
shane gill stereotype it was on the the
last flagrant too shanghai
yeah
he said you know he said he was in a
stand-up line i thought
he just stand up live and you know the
year's show went well and i'm walking
out and um there's a bar stand up live
and uh there's a couple sitting there
and this big
like guy sitting there like older guy
but big turns around and goes that's the
worst [ __ ] set i've ever seen and
shane you know he goes you know to have
fans talk to you like that because they
want your attention yeah and he goes
haha thanks dude it was fun he goes no
no dude that was the worst stand up i've
ever [ __ ] heard i want my [ __ ]
money back and then shane goes i could
tell from his tone and the way he looked
like he was dead serious and then shane
goes off you know he's basically like
[ __ ] you man and i guess they get each
other's face out be separated
god damn
that's oh yeah they got like a shoving
mattress yeah what kind of an [ __ ]
who is this [ __ ] who would do that
but then train goes maybe he's military
and i do have a navy seal joke that
doesn't sit well with him
i'm such a sad she's such a savage but
it's also that that means i bet those
people didn't know who shane gillis was
like they're certain comics like shane
gillis tim dillon schultzy for that
matter if you don't know who they are
and you're just like oh let's go to a
show oh show up you're like what in the
[ __ ] yeah you're gonna be offended so at
that point one time i was in san diego
at the comedy store and cindy was a
heavy military talent you would have all
the dirt you're watching i remember one
time i was doing a thing and i was doing
this thing about sparta and it was all
navy seals they were just navy seals
they were like
so you'd always have these rough rangers
seals marines that'd always be there and
this girl
this woman i didn't know she was opening
for me super liberal and she was
criticizing the military but in a really
bad way like and you know like the
military it's like it's like intel
military intelligence noxie [ __ ] like
okay your intelligence but you're in the
military yeah right and it just gets so
quiet
it's so quiet she keeps eating a dick
and she keeps wearing that you just hear
this guy go this just this guy goes he's
just kiss my and she goes something like
wow you guys you guys are quiet or
something he goes you just hear him go
kiss my ass [ __ ]
[Laughter]
the whole place
she had to leave early and that's
awesome
the guy found me he's like you know he
was talking to me hey sorry about that
schultzy said uh
this guy was heckling he kicked him out
in the crowd you know that puts the
crowd on their toes kind of [ __ ] up the
rhythm of the of the night you know and
uh so she goes are we good you gotta be
quiet and then there's silence and
here's some guy go stay quiet if you're
gay
and drills goes it was so funny i
couldn't help but break man because i
started laughing
well stay quiet if you're gay so i
didn't tell you this in schaumburg when
i was there there was i'm doing my set
it was like a saturday early show or
friday early show and i just hear i'm i
do event and i just hear yeah
and i'm like man that's weird and i i
care about things
[Applause]
and i go all right yeah where the [ __ ]
is that coming from sure enough it's two
dudes who are
good look like kind of pros you know
kind of shaved heads with jerseys on
kind of my my audience and then and then
a gal and then this this blonde who was
just
blind see her husband kind of go on man
talk to her and then the
sure enough the people come up security
come over and they're like hey and then
she won't leave she's like oh santa
staying here i ain't even doing so she's
not making any sense yeah so now i start
making fun of her and and the the guys
then she's just i'll leave it i leave
her husband now sits across from her in
the other seat and he's like we gotta go
yeah please oh my god
i didn't know
i was way out she's making no [ __ ]
sense i'm not even saying you can't you
can't continue oh dude i just made it a
huge joke i just started until she
leaves yeah and they had to move
everybody out and the poor guys were
like we're big fans i'm sorry bro and i
go bro do you have me they never did i
go dm me on my instagram or email me i
get my email i go i will get you tickets
you just can't bring drunky believe
drinks too much jesus christ she's just
clearly had a problem how's the guy i've
almost never had how about the guy
waiting for shane gillis
yeah the fact that the fact that he was
what was that what's the navy seal joke
is it do you know it i'm sure it's a
shane gilles i'm sure it's it's a new
it's a newer one yeah but still yeah
that's really weird that somebody would
wait that long why would they be that
offended because he's not offensive he's
just like
might be do you see us being offensive
did you see i don't think it's offensive
but it's the trending topic
because people are like oh i'm going to
watch more of this now it's like number
three on netflix oh he knows here's the
thing too dummies that want to cancel
chappelle over that
you should go after netflix if you're
really trying to do some but it doesn't
matter there's such an empire but you
realize that when you submit an hour to
netflix they review everything it's not
like the workers that i'm flicks like he
said what yeah they know exactly it's
about freedom of speech yeah so probably
the netflix executives went to one of
his live shows saw the hour then okayed
it yeah so your problem although it's
with chappelle is the platform that gave
him the platform yeah but it's also
hilarious it's also they should give him
that it's also fantastic you're allowed
to say yeah this is he just there's an
mit professor an mit professor he was
giving a speech on climate change the
mit professor said
that in some instances certain programs
like affirmative action tend to create
prejudice against groups and it doesn't
work out for all groups and it's a very
hard thing to implement and he was very
eloquent about speaking about it he was
talking i did an interview but it had
nothing to the climate change mit
because there was an uproar about him
being racist and it's just a point of
view that actually 74 of americans from
all agree with backgrounds black white
everything agree with it it's not
controversial it's always been something
like wait a minute and i don't know why
what's his name uh i can't remember but
he got they they rescinded his offer
and we're dealing now with universities
they're so gutless that the minute
there's a little twitter storm they
dis-invite speakers and he wasn't even
talking about it he was talking about
[ __ ] climate change
what did netflix the ceo say about
chappelle he just defends him netflix
ceo ted sorando's defense dave chappelle
special trans uh yeah and then uh one
the employees got because she sent out
tweets they suspended or fired her i
think there was uh there was another i
think this might be the same employee
she was the showrunner for dear white
people she's like boycotting netflix
until they take down chappelle you know
what netflix is doing who can go [ __ ]
we'll make money okay cool yeah
chappelle makes us hundreds of millions
of dollars do you bring how much in it's
market value okay cool
so he said several you have asked where
we draw the line on hate uh we don't
allow titles netflix are designed to
entice hate or violence we don't believe
that closure crosses the line i
recognize however that distinguished
between commentaries harm is hard
especially stand-up counter which exists
to push boundaries some people find that
art of stamp to be mean spirit but our
members enjoy it it's important part of
our content offering wait they think
he's hating this is how you fight back
you fight back yeah yeah
when these major stream finales when
these major networks go we're leaving it
dude this isn't we're not canceling you
you know i thought dana white the way
he'd when when they said the the new
york times said that you shouldn't be
having this event during copenhagen i
don't give a [ __ ] what the new york
times says they go yes but what he goes
i don't give a [ __ ] that journalist got
some clicks good for them you move on i
don't give a [ __ ] there is that there is
that this was the only way you beat it
well well they weren't even
they speak for a very small minority but
also netflix is all they care about is
numbers
if you know anybody at netflix all they
care about is numbers so they're looking
at all right how many people watch dave
chappelle special what's the you know
what's the conversion rate how many
people finished it and it's like one of
the most watched apps you also don't
have to it's all numbers you're also
allowed to say things people disagree
netflix doesn't care yeah they they're
it's literally a numbers game
so they're saying all right so that lady
who was like i'm not riding until you
kick off dave chappelle okay so netflix
goes how many people watch oh wow how
many watch dave's okay let's side with
dave that's right
no matter what they believe yeah it's
called the marketplace it's called
business yeah but also i don't think a
lot of these people watched his whole
special no there's there's just no way
it's like because if you would think he
was hating on something you then you
didn't watch this [ __ ]
he goes hard in the paint but like this
activist journalist but let's just call
him an activist his name is butterworth
i can't remember he was on pierce morgan
and he was he was going crazy on jk
rowling's new book because it was
transphobic and it wasn't and he and he
says uh did you read the book
and he said no i didn't read it oh wow
but and it was like wow how does that
happen all that happens all the time
you'll never hear me criticizing anyone
because think about it because if you go
hard in chapelle it's making news now
like i saw an article on my news feed it
was like
five lgbqt comics that are funny and
dave if you're sick of his stuff it's
like okay
okay wow
come on
well they they break people up into
groups i don't i treat everybody as an
individual and that's how you should do
it no his special was by far his best at
the last [ __ ] did you see did you see
what it is no longer lgbtq it is now 2s
for two spirit
look up what justin trudeau now
uh referred to
marginalized communities as he's who's
the bigger [ __ ] him or newsom uh
trudeau i don't know they should have a
[ __ ] up yeah yeah who's trudeau
oh he's the uh premier of he's the he's
he's the prime minister of canada canada
that guy his dad was the long-time peer
trainer was the long time three-term i
think now trudeau's got in trouble
because he's been caught in blackface
multiple yeah that guy yeah okay i
remember but he's he's uh how do i
search this bar
cabinet he just he just made 50 of them
women it wasn't it had nothing to do
with with qualifications qualifications
just had to do with genitalia he was
like if you don't have well we need a
certain number of vaginas and certain
number of gonads and i'm just gonna make
it you know no news from before he
leaves wants to do the most
crazy woke left stuff
yeah like the stuff he's passing
subs
yeah it's gonna fight what is nancy
pelosi's worth 350 million it's better
that they do this stuff because then
it's going to get even democrats like
holy [ __ ] this out of control it's
better he does this crazy yeah what else
you got jen
all ready
so a wedding photographer went to his
friend's wedding and he was going to
shoot a 10-hour wedding day for 250
he says that he was just helping his
friend
out right right kyle
what up
that's a pretty pretty low 250 for 10
hours yeah
no absolutely i wouldn't get out of bed
for that
so he was doing this as a favor to his
friend because his friend says i'm on a
shoestring budget i really need a
photographer i don't really care if it's
great photos i just want photos from
that day so his friend shows up takes
photos and it's a very hot day he also
finds out halfway through that he was
not reserved a plate to eat he was
expected to take photos throughout the
entire thing no lunch break
uh his friend was did not allow him to
refill his water bottle and when the
friend confronted the groom he said hey
i need to at least get 20 minutes just
to go somewhere grab some food and come
back his friend gave him an ultimatum
saying you can leave and not get your
250 dollars
or you can stay finished the day and get
your payment at the very end
so the photographer actually took it
upon himself to go and delete all of the
photos from that day in front of the
groom he posted this online wanting to
see if he was the [ __ ] for
doing that in front of his friend or if
it was justified and a lot of people are
supposed to most people agree with him
some people think it's [ __ ] up yeah
what do you think kyle i think what's
[ __ ] up is 100 percent justified yeah
yeah why yeah i wouldn't have brought it
to the internet i don't do that i want
to just stand stand the ground of just
like [ __ ] yeah that's what i did
so where's the where's the social media
side with him
social media for the most part is with
him there are a few people who say that
he should have kept the photos and
charged his friends double or triple the
price he would have uh sold the photos
for originally
and then there are some people saying oh
that's mean you should have just kept it
for him anyways he's never going to get
this moment back i would have but most
people are on the photographer's side
what i would have done is if you you
treat me that way i would have gone like
this so you say just tell me i can't
refill my water you can't have water
just take the pictures okay cool just
take my camera i just turn around and i
just
walk away i don't even say it i go like
this like okay okay sorry about that no
i've been like
no i've been like all right cool dude so
i have whatever 100 something pictures
i'm not working the ven anymore because
i was doing it as a favor so now if you
want these it's triple the price well i
would just i'm not going to delete them
but if you want these tributes that's
all yeah i'm just not going to delete
them but if you want them now i'm out
dude well because you hurt my feelings
so that's going to be well i would just
say
i'm just going to charge my regular rate
like this is the worst gig ever so if
you want these pictures i'm done i'm
gonna take any more if you want these
it's triple the cost yeah
the guy also i don't think is a
photographer originally he works at a
pet store but okay so i don't really
know where the group is right yeah
he'll treat his wife the same way just
watch it if that's a true story that's
that's a bad guy
have you dreamed of a friend like that
it may not be true hey hit him up man
maybe you can get a turtle was his wife
like is that the guy that deals with the
hamsters the pet store getting like yeah
it's my buddy's also a part-time
photographer 250 bucks
why don't you catch in
here we go
okay so this story was sent in by dean
sidoris there is an article that where
the rock claims that he tried steroids
when he was 18 19 he was had a short
stint
but he claims that he has never touched
steroids since
the years of 18 and 19. i love this yeah
hold on wait he says he's steroid free
and all of it is not really true he said
he's this what is his site
it's an article from muscle and fitness
he did an interview wow
now you want to negate the hard work you
put in dude you work hard
no i'm not i'm not down that is he
suggesting that does he consider
testosterone maybe he doesn't consider
testosterone on steroids
he just says that he has never touched a
steroid okay so human growth hormone and
testosterone is that
what he's including in there could be is
that for
he's on steroids but also
but also
i think he has to do this right because
if he came out and gave us like his
cycle yeah then i'm like oh what a piece
of [ __ ] and then he wants a [ __ ]
yeah like he's like he's kid-friendly
yeah so he has to double down this i
don't know that's him rapping which is
yes this is shipping bro this should go
hard
his verse actually goes hard
the rock has a new song out he is
yeah he did a song with tech nine and a
couple other cats uh it's his song but
yeah he's the last verse doesn't he do
but he he actually doesn't sound like
someone in my veins my culture is
banging with strange
i guess he has to do that but arnold
never admitted he was on steroids either
like those guys just uh they really
can't
not not it's just really frowned upon
you just i mean it's such a bad message
for kids but if you look at it but but
if if i'm him i don't know why like he
did that article for muslim fitness like
his people handling it should be like
hey no steroid questions like you
shouldn't even touch
all the gear yeah name steroid what's in
his veins
oh and that's fine
but just don't comment on it like like
phil heath you know when remembering the
show like there's no mention like we all
know
the elephant in the room the juicy
steroid elephant in the room yeah but no
one alludes to it you know he's like
yeah i take cell tack i'm like okay well
he got huge out of nowhere because i
remember that what was that movie he did
with the little girl where he was a
football player tooth fairy no not tooth
fairies
game plan he was a lot smaller in game
plan and then that movie he did with uh
mark wahlberg and uh
yeah clarence yeah he's always that's a
great movie he's a good guy he's games
painting games playing a game that's
what he was like so look at him there
wow and then typing type him uh painting
game but i think what people understand
is he start like his
his starting is so much higher than like
he's a big dude in general he's lean and
big so he's probably not on it right
there
probably not and probably but look at
him in pain again
so when he did painting game look how
huge he was yeah and look at mark
wahlberg like look at him
that's all nettie from mark you have
when you have traps like that
but look up to put the picture there
chin with his shirt off he do that's
which one the one he's 50 something
years old dude
how are you seeing his 50. how do you
want to pretend that he's not on [ __ ]
but also i mean i look like that but
also like
my thing with this is like he he should
just comment on it but b
dude do all the same [ __ ] he's doing
you're not going to be as big as the
rock can i be shredded the wrong super
talented
who's that guy late late 40 how old's
the rock jen
48 49 at least
oops
40 49 49. like no 49 year olds that big
and shredded and run it that hard
without supplementation that's just
science baby yeah
and it's fine dude it's fine i don't
care
do you see people are clowning on uh vin
diesel because he's on that yacht with
his shirt off he has a gut yeah some
hater was like clowning on him and then
tyreese actually stuck up for him went
dude you're at home with no yacht and a
shirt
that's pretty good
iris yeah
he's like you don't have he's had a
moment and you have a shirt he had a
moment of kind of crazy but he seems
like a good person then
i don't i don't know i don't know
i don't know him at all
yeah what else you got jen
all righty
let's look at a good one here
um what about madonna
so i just saw her on jimmy fallon she
like flashed the crowd she with her ass
went on the desk and then she flashed
her she has a fake ass yeah she has a
dude it's so fake but she actually looks
pretty she's 60 something 60. she's in
her 60s
mid 60s
yeah she's uh one of the kids
63 holy [ __ ] 63 so i i honestly before
this interview i thought she looked kind
of crazy but she actually looks pretty
good for 16 three of her would she just
show her ass yeah i'll show you right
now
she got a grill
how old score are these shows not only
this afternoon but
stop it
so that's what she does first
she's she is a force of nature
you don't look better you don't look
better than that at 60.
she got a house right under the
hollywood sign
i'm sorry
that booty is fake
definitely fake but i should definitely
looks good for 69. should we go quietly
without a fight she will me tonight like
cher let her do it yeah she is fighting
the [ __ ] she's amazing yep she's
fighting father time man she's worse
than me she's kind of winning you know
she's up on the cards i'll give her that
uh this is what corey anderson posted i
don't know this is where it's from but
some dude that hits a car you'll see
right now
cory answers a ufc fighter
god yeah
no he's a bellator fighter oh he was ufc
fighter how did that happen yeah it's a
kid who for some reason i wasn't paying
attention probably on his phone probably
and then oh and it breaks his face oh my
god yeah it's going to hurt he has a
mask on yeah
jesus christ it would have turned out
differently he reads with the mask
outside that guy
yeah so if you want disneyland now the
fastpass system is gone you have to pay
20 like 20 bucks yeah up to 20 bucks to
do fast pass i'll pay for a fast pass
yeah i pay more there's different ones
yeah they have different options as well
but i mean if that gets me not doing
those goddamn lines
whatever it takes whatever it's a
nightmare have you been recently
nightmare no i'm not the lines are so
long can't go yeah so disney genie plus
it's not right
for a couple seconds no
are you going for halloween
uh
my buddy ryan showed me this a 69 year
old woman on only fans is like in the
top one percent
good for her
yeah that's her hold up and she makes
170 grand a month sleeping with younger
men
140k and euros so whatever that is yeah
and she uh she'll go to different areas
and she'll say like say it again she
will go to different areas and she'll
ask like if anyone's down to come and
have sex with her on camera
younger guys and then of course they
would come oh wow
they would come literally too let her do
her thing that's her her disabled son's
like mom how are we making i know so she
she had no idea
she had no idea she would make this much
money but now she's oh there you go
there are a lot of guys that are into
that so yep god bless you and uh i went
to her twitter because they posted it
here on twitter there's some stuff on
there the first thing i saw pop up was
her
like
having a big black dick in her in her
mouth all right so i'm not sure i didn't
click on this yet so we'll do it right
now together
together
yeah
some guy paid for that
how are we hold up i'm surprised her
caption is
power restored last night 12 long days
in the heat now the cleanup begins
between him covet and the hurricane i've
lost a lot of fans and only fans help a
guy by subscribing thank you kindly
and then this person put
at m7056
wow you are amazing those tits are just
wow
all right 69.
she's 69 69 years old let her do it
madonna has nothing on her
yeah
that's the only fan just a big black
dick
yeah
and we were talking a bunch in this i
don't know how people find these things
but
what i just can't believe i have kids i
don't know what to do
my dog my [ __ ] turtle was murdered
now this
well brian so we've been tagged a bunch
in this i don't know how people like i
said i don't know how people find it but
people find people that look like oh my
god
and our bodies are not that similar
he just has cats
my god same hair that's what i look like
if i made a lot of bad decisions wow
damn
that's pretty damn that's pretty damn
close
that is pretty damn good
all right who sent it or was just a
bunch of people oh yeah i saw i might
watch that hey guys not me
handsome fella
damn that's not me oh wow that is
[ __ ] he's just got a song brother got
arrested
my evil twin brother made some bad
choices yeah he's gonna start a gofundme
uh this friday saturday only friday
saturday brea improv this friday
saturday me and the crew will be there
friday saturday two shows friday two
show saturday break california november
11th through the 13th dallas addison
improv special night special night
november 11th to 13th that's dallas
texas addison improv chicago got
rescheduled because we're doing a fight
companion for that one so that is not on
there
i'm going to be in uh magooby's uh
that's it timonium
october 14th to the 16th then i got
liberty township uh and i that's in
cincinnati back to ohio october 22nd
23rd the funny bone get your tickets and
then uh november 11 12 13 14 i'm at off
the hook comedy club those tickets just
went on sale yeah and by the way october
20th i'm going to be a jam in the van
here in l.a october's one of you yeah
you want to come i'm on it are you yeah
october 21 chappelle lacey october 20th
yeah
what time i don't know i don't know
uh october 28th through the 30th i'll be
in washington dc at the dc
comedy loft november 17th tacoma comedy
club november 18th spokane comedy club
get your tickets f-a-t-k-z dot com braya
see you this weekend bye-bye we're out